un procès qui s'achève aux assises d'aix
en provence dans la plus grande
incertitude le procès de christian
ranucci 21 ans accusé du rapt et de
l'assassinât d'une fillette de 8 ans
maria dolores tremble quoique
circonstances de ce drame ne soit pas
tout à fait identique pour ne peut
évidemment éviter le cas rapprochement
avec le rapt et l'assassinât de philippe
bertrand
ce petit garçon de 3 et effectivement
les personnalités les deux accusés ont
des points communs
rien dans leur famille dans leur fille
ne semblait prédestiner à accomplir un
tel qu une voix calme avec les fonds
d'actions des provinces qui contredit
les mots qui tombent à village de grand
père de l'enfant
l'avocat général viala et les panneaux
mais redoutable qui captivent
l'attention de la convaincre 4-4 il a
requis la peine de mort contre christian
ranucci l'homme dans son dos semblait se
targue dehors la foule ses défis ses
formes et de curieux d'avis que les
passionnés pour ou contre la peine de
mort je n'ai jamais vu une défense des
avocats repousser autant la limite de
leurs moyens et de leurs convictions ils
ont bien fait leur métier lui est créé
le doute c'est à dire travailler ou
faire grandir cette idée de mesures de
calques certains appellent la sérénité
de la justice une tâche énorme devant la
commission que tous avaient de la
culpabilité
l'écriture année je vends aussi le fait
qu'il ne faut pas dissimuler de l'homme
à être accusé de rapts et meurtres
d'enfants semblait aux yeux d'apporter
les visages d'autres meurtriers
supporter le poids de profits plongera
[ __ ] le procès de christian ranucci
est venue rappeler nous rappeler que le
crime n'est pas forcément le fait de la
demande
le team est une tâche ou de tous les
jours même pour un organisme ou un
esprit d'équilibré magnifique ne voulez
vous pas que cette enfant il l'a fait
tout de même lors c'est quelque chose
c'est d'être à cannes son esprit
l'espace d'un instant ce qui nous
arrivait à chacun par une réduction
soudaine du désir de la peur il de
l'intérêt
le procédé est qu au delà de l'homme
devenu un exemple le rappel contre la
raison et le crime ne se trouvent
souvent